- So I heard that someone famous
showed up at your wedding
that your mom was more excited about
than you getting married.
(Jay and Kelly laughing)
- Yeah so I've known Anna Kendrick,
we were introduced through
a good friend of ours,
Tommy Alter, who hosts this
podcast with JJ Redick.
And we were out at dinner one night
and we were all talking about summer plans
and everyone was like,
"Oh I'mma be in Europe.
I'mma be in Europe."
And we're like okay cool.
Like if we see each other, sure
we'll bump into each other.
Literally she was in Florence
the weekend of my wedding.
- [Kelly] What?
- Yeah she knew the date.
She knew the date.
- She was like, "Oh that's so weird."
- Anna knew the date but-
- She's a wedding crasher, I like it.
- I'm not gonna say
that, but no, but no so-
- I wanna say that, that
makes her even more lovable.
It's awesome.
- She came, she was a champ.
She actually came as like a plus one
to this like kickoff
drinks thing that we did
like two days before the
wedding with a buddy of mine.
And I was like,
"You gotta come to the
wedding, you're in town.
How crazy is this? You gotta come."
Like how random is it that
you're in the same place? Come.
She's like, "I can't
do it. I won't do it."
And I'm like-
"I can't find a dress."
You're in Italy, you can find a dress.
- Yes.
- It's dresses everywhere in
Italy, you can find a dress.
So finally she gets to the wedding
and literally after the ceremony,
my mom walks over to me
and pulls me to the side
and my mom is like, "Did you
know Anna Kendrick was here?"
(Kelly laughing)
And I was like, "Yeah mom."
- Well it is my wedding.
- And she's like,
"I took a picture with her."
(Kelly laughing)
And I was like, "Mom I just got married.
Literally, I just got married."
- So let's just, perspective.
- Let's just-
- Bring it in.
- We're still at the
wedding, just so you know.
(Kelly laughing)
But it was a good time.
- We're supposed to be up
here in importance right now.
She's like, "I'm over you."